rat how much you know about construction
what do you know I've got the basics you
know shop class
when you're building flats on set you
know how they have walls and you can
turn those walls you can change those
walls up building those huh I love how
you have the dimensions written down
like 10 foot high 8 foot wide clean
I gotta get gas by the way I only put 91
in this you got no gas
oh the gas gauge doesn't work what you
got
Metallica Black Album
[Music]
we need to look at what sort of why
would they have first we're kind of a
comment is that I mean not the
top was gonna be more work look at that
this will be fine listen just help me
with these you're gonna hold it a good
so here's a work some people I did
it gives more meaning out of life when
you my kid owes it to Jim you go to an
orphanage so right yes I'm saying war
board signs sometimes the war children
of that that's boards are the best and
step one complete we've got the 4x8
birch boards and now we're gonna go get
the framing it's all war finish it
this one is this a good one I heard you
oh yeah that's doing all right this one
is funny look at this one oh man
it's good that's real nice see that it's
real nice is that one of those adopted
son son
it seems that most people are unclear on
how a ratchet strap works every other
time I give ratchet straps to somebody
and they bring them back to me they're
bundled up like this incorrectly this is
an avoidable problem people I'm going to
do a quick tutorial after I unbind this
one and we're going to learn how to
solve this
yeah it's kind of cooking we can cookie
in my jackets on just found a cookie
this is my jacket guy it is such
a pain in the ass ticket because as you
unbind it it gets either becomes less
and less slack to work with it becomes
more and more difficult to actually
unbind I don't understand how the world
doesn't know how to drive stick
shifts or ratchet ratchet straps this is
basic people we're probably on the
track a little bit retro ask you to
supervise puppies
attend an ice-cream Lieutenant Dan just
never loan a ratchet strap because if
you know how to ratchet you already have
your own and if you don't you're gonna
it up
so there's never loan a ratchet that's
the bottom line
oh my god there's another one after that
you got to be kidding me I'm gonna go
grab a water dude this is unbelievable
who did this and then do this
for the purpose of the tutorial almost
there
ass there was only one rat in our suit
sure yeah have you seen any evidence of
another one do you think they went
shooting in the food they come out every
night around your brats do that's why
rats are the lowest animals now do your
arms are great arms our life gamers
about blue belly lizards three billion
lizards or just reptiles man they didn't
do anything
here's how you do a ratchet strap you
have your basic ratchet like that it
closes this way you take the other end
you bring it underneath like that okay
you see that underneath the metal the
middle Teac and then you go through the
middle right there underneath and
through the middle so that well your
ratcheting this end is sticking out if
this end is getting wrapped up
underneath what's your ratcheting you
did it wrong this end should be sticking
out so that when you ratchet it bundles
here but it doesn't bundle your pulley
that way you can get it undone without
having to do what I just did for 25
minutes in a Home Depot parking lot Bret
thank you for the water I apologize for
swearing in your general direction well
I was undoing the straps it was just a
little frustrating
okay you know sometimes you wanna you
see somebody in the troubling spot and
they look like they want to cookies
wanna see your bathrobe ow
that's right first step is to put the
wall faces out and then see how we need
to set up the frame then once you put
all the pieces in place for the frame
you mark them with letters so you know
where they go and then you just put it
all together pretty simple just set this
we did it before Trump is on this wall
expands we're making the final touches
although this is the prototype and I
think one thing we learned from the
prototype is that we want to be able to
store these as effectively as possible
so instead of nailing these into the
wall next time I'm just going to use
metal hooks
it'll just drop right in we can do with
a 8 by 8 foot wall without labor or
anything just the materials for about
140 bucks not super cheap but it's in
the grand scheme of things if it allows
us to shoot in here more saves us
location money freaking destroy them
shoot at them paint all over them
dirty them up whatever you want to do to
them you can do because they're just
fake walls you have to worry about
ruining your nice real walls pretty
sweet